DESERT FORD DEALERS.
THE DUCKS IN REBOUND!
REILLY SMITH IN THE CLEARKARLSS.
GIBSON WITH THE FIRST SAVE.
A BEAUTIFUL
HAS A LITTLE SPACE.
HIS SHOT BLOCKED IN FRONT.
THE FLIP IN DEEP
SHATAT
NICOLAS HAGUE WITH A BOMB FROM
THE HIGH SLOT, PAST
JOHN GIBSON.
AND NICOLAS HAGUE WITH HIS
SECOND
LOOKING TO BREAK.
MARCHESSAULT TRYING TO CATCH
HIM.
THE BACKHAND, SAVE THAT
RIGHT MITT.
AS I AWAY AND ZEGRAS SCORES.
A TWO-GOAL LEAD BACK.
GIBSON REACHED BACK. SCORES!
WILLIAM CARRIER RIPS HOME HIS
FIRST OF THE SEASON, AND THE
GOGO
HE
THE GOLDEN
KNIGHTS, AND THE DUCKS BACK TO
THE FEED WIDE OPEN.
TROY TERRY GOES TO THE
ISAC LUNDESTROM ON THE DOORSTEP
ON THE REBOUND!
POINT.
THAT MINUTES. THE DUCKS WITH AYE
WALL.
ALLOWED SHATTENKIRK TO COME OFF.
WEDNESDAY.
THE ONLY GAME THAT'S GONE BEYOND
REGULATION FOR THEM THIS YEAR.
INTO THE ANAHEIM ZONE.
DRIVING WIDE.
FEEDS IT BACK.ENSON COMING,
T.
>> CHANDLER STEPHENSON'S SPEED
IS INCREDIBLE.
HISS AND
ANAHEIM.
50% EFFICIENCY
LEHNER AFTER ROY EXTENDS IT.
ABLE OF HIS
CAREER AND